Paulie pointed out this story to me
I think it's via Darren Revell ESPN
sports business reporter final out last
year's World Series Chicago Cubs finally
win the World Series and first base was
auctioned off for $100,000 is that right
Paulie that's the report do you think it
would gone for a lot more if there was
first base friendly yeah
yes because they now the Indians gave
them force base right unless you just
pick it up like you're Ricky Henderson
and hold it above your head and say
you're the great there's some all-time
spring and Darrin Revell the mothership
is that is that how this played out
Darrin that they they also the way it
were Major League Baseball's Major
League Baseball's properties okay so
they they were rotating in and out bases
and all these things for Game seven so
this is actually the base just from
innings nine and ten the Cubs won in in
the tents so it's a two inning I don't
know how many people actually touch the
base we have to go back but it's 100
1000 bucks and it might not seem like
that much in the game use auction world
but I could only find there were a
couple like Jeter game bases that
weren't for in the $40,000 range nothing
even close
like other World Series bases went for
like seven eight thousand dollars so
collecting game-used bases really isn't
a thing and just to see what some of
these sold for last night a hundred
thousand for this the Cubs on-deck
circle from games one two six and seven
so for $40,000 and for some reason I
think I guess an Indians fan purchased
the Jon Lester wild pitch ball that that
scored two Indians runs they went up 5-3
in the seventh for $11,000 gosh but
explain this to me though when is this
normal that they swap out the bases for
for auction yeah I mean Major League
Baseball now
a robust business of not only
authenticating gear but selling gear if
you go to any major league baseball
placin in 1985 I wanted to get a st.
Patrick's Day Jersey from the Mets that
they wore during spring training I wrote
a letter and guess what they send me one
it doesn't work that way it can't work
now all these parks have you know
authentic shops and they're they're
generating you know opportunities to
have game use stuff and so when I was at
the Diamondbacks just to opener just a
regular opener for the Diamondbacks this
year every three innings they're
swapping out bases authenticating them
tagging them with Holograms I mean yeah
and especially for for big games it's
now moved to a new point of insanity
where all these guys by the way who are
authenticating them are former police
officers they're there you know putting
down the hologram they're scanning the
hologram they're going to the back rooms
they're watching it with their eyes and
then it goes to be sold so this is a
major operation is the NFL doing the
same the other sports doing the same the
NFL does does it the NBA does it the NHL
does it a little bit but nothing like
baseball
there's baseballs in a class of its own
all right well that leads us to the Eli
Manning topic and how did this story
come to light about three years ago
there was just a story about a guy who
originally it was hey there's this
disgruntled you know former memorabilia
guy who bought 275 jerseys from the
Giants and the Giants had said on
various occasions that they weren't real
even though the equipment manager had
told him through you know direct sales
that you know this is the genuine item
he was the the the plaintiffs the guy
who came who sued the Giants and Eli
Manning was indicted for essentially
memorabilia fraud by a federal
during in 2011 and then this the the FBI
the feds couldn't find anything and so
the charges were dropped and then he
basically said I know who did this now
whether they did or not the Giants are
the ones who pointed me to the feds and
said I was the one making you know fake
memorabilia the the truth is that they
are and started this process with this
lawsuit which in the beginning was less
detailed than it is now but essentially
that the equipment manager for the
Giants had had an operation to allegedly
manufacture stuff to be game used when
it was not and that Eli Manning he had
heard as part of conversations was you
know not only complicit in it but was
very well aware of what was going on in
some misdemeanor or felony for Eli my
attention right now right right now it's
a civil case if it was if it was a a
criminal case and it was still within
the statute of limitations which is no
longer every allegation in here is
either five years old at least five
years old or almost to the point of five
years old which means that a criminal
case could not be brought against the
Giants and they couldn't manager an Eli
Manning so right right now it is just a
a civil action and there is a big
differentiator here because obviously if
Eli Manning and the and the Giants and
equipment manager were facing
racketeering and fraud charges at the
criminal level then it might not even be
up to the NFL to do anything they could
be in jail if they were indeed found you
know to to to have done this so right
now what we have is a a civil case which
got ratcheted up last week when the the
plaintiffs basically submitted to the
court an email from Eli's AOL email in
2010 believe it or not still using a law
yeah good job Eli but that base
he's saying asking the equipment manager
if he could get two helmets that would
quote pass as game-used which obviously
that that terminology is a little bit
strange and is the first kind of
evidence the plaintiffs say that Eli
Manning was very well aware of the
manufacture of game use memorabilia as
Eli spoken no nothing nothing since this
email which is all all I'd want to hear
I would I would just say what's what's
interesting is that you know a lot of
these organizations NFL in particular
come off as very very arrogant to begin
with and I'm not saying that that
they're guilty here I'm just saying that
their arrogance certainly does does come
off and and I don't know I think that
sometimes hurts them in in in situations
like this so we'll see what this email
does there is a hard hard and fast trial
date of September 25th and and we'll see
if it makes it to trial or if this email
is kind of gonna lead to some sort of
settlement Darren thanks for joining us
I stay on the case there
I will hi buddy let's say Darren Revell
ESPN Sports Business reporter the thing
about swapping out the bases I found
interesting like you just yeah and are
those is the money donated to charity
does Major League Baseball is you know
what I'm sorry that's one of the funnier
things I probably said I hope that it
would be charitable the Major League
Baseball would be swapping out these
bases the beat that'd be a nice story
for the kids yeah it's always for the
kids the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience